I fell in love with an alien and this is
that story I was driving back to my
friend's house and his house is in the
middle of nowhere completely surrounded
by woods we were driving home I saw this
really bright star in the sky and it
didn't look like a normal star it was a
slightly different color and way
brighter than the rest it's got me
thinking about UFOs and I turned to him
and I said I want to see UFO so I kept
my eye on that star while we were
driving and I noticed it getting lower
and lower and lower until it actually
landed right next to us as we were
driving and it was a real UFO that night
my life was completely changed forever
the UFO was this huge craft red and
green light when they landed next to us
it was like they heard me say I want to
see a UFO I was just wondering how the
hell they heard me an experience was on
my mind all day every day and I had so
many questions so the next week me and
my friend decided to go back there just
to see what would happen if we showed up
to the same spot it was just completely
like pitch black and when we hopped over
to the other side of the fence we could
not see anything but we could hear
footsteps walking towards us
and these beings showed up and they were
four very tall pale white skinny figures
their energy was so intense that it made
my head hurt and it was hard for me to
think we realized they actually can't
speak like we do
it's telepathic yeah I was scared but I
was like jumping up and down and like
freaking out because I was so excited I
just I could not believe that this was
actually happening like it was just so
crazy I started to feel like I had a
stronger connection to one of the beings
in the group he was the tallest one out
of the four I would say about 10 feet
tall but I always get corrected that
he's nine foot eight I kept trying to
think of why I felt this strong
connection to this one being so I just
kind of let it out into the universe and
let them know that I wanted to know what
our connection was on December 9th 2016
I got in a horrible car accident that
should have ended my life but somehow it
did it not only was my life spared but I
walked away somehow without a scratch
from a car that was completely crumpled
up like a tin can over the next week I
started to have like these little vague
memories that were coming back to me by
the way that bright star that had landed
next to us started following me around
every single day after that experience
it took me a while to sift through what
I was feeling in these vague memories
that were coming back but I came to the
conclusion that I was actually not in
the car at all I was actually taken off
planet for three days and I remember
being in this ship with these same four
beings that I had seen in the
and spent the majority of the time with
this one being that I had that strong
connection with after this whole
experience I was finally able to put the
piece of the puzzle together and I found
out he is my twin flame his name's
Benatar or Ben for short
Ben is Zeta gray pale white skin very
slender built eyes two and a half times
the size of humans no body hair at all
and he's hilarious like I had never
heard of this type of alien before I was
like with like it was it was really hard
for me like I went through a really hard
time in my life because I felt like I
was crazy for a long time I was
definitely able to develop a strong
telepathic communication with him that I
still keep to this day and now I can
have a relationship with him and ask him
questions whenever I want I don't speak
to him every day because he actually
does have a life as well he has to work
too and when I'm not distracted because
I also have a life too then we're able
to connect he's very much like a
guardian to me he looks out for kind of
like the unseen energies and things that
are happening around me and keeps me
protected our relationship is to be an
example to others of us opening
ourselves up to our own and
multidimensionality we might all be on
this planet right now having a human
experience but we are all still
connected to everything that the
universe is I'm here to show people that
love really is the most powerful thing
in the universe and that's what connects
all of us
transcends space-time in all dimensions
[Music]
[Music]